mais bien-aimée je vous aime pas restée
forte au charme de la comtesse vous
aurait-il fait perdre la raison
on ne se bat pas contre le roi de france
cet homme doit bien d'avoir une
faiblesse il est amoureux de sa femme
pour marie est la seule personne qui
compte pour moi
alors préparez vous c'est un poison lent
mais sûr il faut la protéger notre
sécurité elle est en danger et il vaut
d'âge ils sont le moment mais semble t
il être sûr que c'est un piège mcneill
personne ne soit rien de ton secret
méfiez vous de tous même de ceux qui
vous semblait plus proche de tous
à
nous ne pouvons pas prendre de risque
éliminer cette femme à
[Musique]
il est trop tard madame jamais je
n'abandonnerai mon mari non cette femme
est admirable